ABC announced Tuesday that Michael  Strahan is exiting live with Kelly and  Michael to join Good Morning America  full time and now there's just one  question on everyone's mind  who will replace him is that there's  some something wonderful just over there  et has learned exclusively that Anderson  Cooper is a contender a production  source tells et quote it's likely Kelly  will bring up Anderson's name as a  replacement they're close friends maybe  there will be a rainbow and it might  land on my head another possibility is  Neil Patrick Harris  I got her present our production source  says producers loved NPH when they were  looking before but Harris did recently  sign on to star in the Netflix  adaptation of the children's book a  series of unfortunate events  you